The Joe Rogan Experience I'm pretty sure
anxiety and depression are baked Into
The Human Experience I don't think you
can get away from them yeah you sound
like a good Catholic that's what I'm
saying man that's what being Catholic I
used to have Wicked panic attacks when I
was 23 and I was also a gigantic piece
of [ __ ] and it was the thing that like
made me start thinking about my life I
was like shocking in my I was like and
if I had just gotten medication I just
would have kept being a giant piece of
[ __ ] so I'm always like making but
sometimes you got to go through you know
what I mean yeah you gotta slide through
that stuff yeah I was a [ __ ] how'd
you pull out of it [ __ ] I just [ __ ]
had to come to grips with the fact I was
gonna die eventually
I had no excuse I had like you know I
wasn't like I was like my back to the
walls like I just like got a couple jobs
like I don't like this I was like I
should sell drugs you know what kind of
drugs are you selling pretty much
everything really weed was the main weed
was the Mainstay but then I started like
I got I got coerced in a pill I didn't
even know what pills did so I was like
my friends would talk me into going and
like finding pills for them turned into
a whole thing dude it was bad news how
did you get out of it just stopped
eventually wow it stopped yeah
now we're good thank you patreon
no it was I had like amazing I didn't
know what pills did and I remember
watching a whole not even a hole but
like it was an apartment complex and
there's these two buildings full of like
all these kids that were living there
there's a long story but like I somehow
got my hands on like Watson
pharmaceutical like jugs of [ __ ] it
was they were Vicodins and like they
were just I didn't I love that I somehow
got my hands on jugs that's never
happened to me that's weird I've never
stolen upon any jugs like open up a
cabinet look at these jugs I don't think
I've ever seen it like what's a jug of
Vicodin how many are we talking dude you
know when you're in the pharmacy and you
look behind the counter it's those big
boys oh like a whey protein bottle yes
scoop protein yeah how much was that
worth uh well at the time it was you're
going to jail you're talking about this
on the podcast you're [ __ ] no statue
of limitations what is the statue of
limitations I don't know
statue of limitations statue statute
statue of limitations dude I'm sure
she's got the shades off
that's basically a thing I was just a
[ __ ] nightmare
that was the thing statute of
limitations that's before the statue of
the statute the French gave us this I
was laying in bed just going what the
[ __ ]
having panic attacks and it forced me to
be like yeah it's probably a pretty bad
idea everything so how did you how'd you
phase out of it I just stopped it it
made me develop like a sense of like
yeah this is [ __ ] other people up and
I like saw people getting [ __ ] up and
I'm like I'm gonna stop doing this you
kept getting robbed at gunpoint and I
kept getting robbed because how many
times you get robbed gunpoint twice whoa
yeah twice twice after the first time
you're like this is never gonna happen
again that's the first time I went back
the plug robbed me at gunpoint and he's
like I won't do it again I was like okay
you said yes daddy the plug what's the
plug the dude who's your supply oh your
supplier robbed you a gun yeah it was
like a it was kind of a mess he I would
give him money and he would go get them
and then one time he came back without
them and he I was like dude just have
them I was so scared of these guys and I
was like you can just keep it all I
don't care and he was like how do I know
you didn't set me up and he's pulled a
gun out on me and I was like
and my roommate walked down and went and
yeah but
yeah and so then you tried to buy from
them again no I told him he like time
passed and he's like dude I'm so sorry I
found out who actually robbed me he's
like if you could come back I'll take
care of you blah blah you know I'll make
it worth your while and I'll just you'll
never have to put any money up ever
again and then what happened I just went
back started yeah and then he ended up
having to just pull his gun uh then
apparently he got in trouble for I think
he tried to shoot at somebody so I went
back to pay him back one time and then
some guy was like nah he's in jail he
tried to kill someone but he tried to
you said he pulled the gun on you twice
once a different guy pulled a gun on me
you said he said he would never do it
again he didn't yeah he's true to his
word so that guy would never do it again
he was the other guy did it some other
guy it was some guy I was in a house and
the guy came in with a gun that was that
stunk what was this about weed pounds
they just said give me your weed yeah he
it was like kind of like one of those
things where like a guy comes in he goes
oh my God some guy happened to be behind
me with a gun everyone get down and I
was sitting there like this is [ __ ]
so then he like just took the money took
like the weed and then he was like
just like who the [ __ ] you know he
started telling me like I was on his
territory and I was like dude come on
man and I just sat there and he just
talked for like two minutes and he was
like if you guys try to look out the
window we're gonna there's people
outside they're gonna shoot you he took
all of her cell phones
I did have a thousand bucks behind my
back though I didn't tell them about so
I got to keep that that's pretty sweet
that was pretty a lot of people would
have lost the composure thankfully that
other guy pulled his gun on you before
so you were dude no what happens though
is you lose
everything slows down and you're able to
like I was in that the first time I just
[ __ ] my pants the second time I was like
looking at the kid who I never met
before who I knew kind of set this up
because I watched one kid I knew like
being a real state of fear and I watched
this other guy pretending to be scared
all while this guy in a ski mask was
like with a gun and it was just like
[ __ ] I really hope like the part of my
brain like I might get shot just went
offline and I was able to watch and be
like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill this little
[ __ ] when this guy you know and
so how long after that did you stop
couple years
I was chasing the bag dude oh my God I
got robbed I didn't make any money I got
robbed constantly I was too trusting
I got robbed cons I got robbed by Club
one time Club Point sucked Club these
guys were like Wellies
[Laughter]
[ __ ] damn yeah he's a non-violent he's a
non-violent drug dealer so how did you
how did you start making money when you
quit I always worked in construction and
stuff too I'd always have a side gig so
I never depended on one too much so I
could always say like [ __ ] you to my job
if I didn't like it and if things got
like weird I could be like I'm not gonna
do I would chill so I had a kind of like
hybrid approach
and how did you get into podcasting I
was just a comedian me and Shane were
just living together I'm like dude can
we please do a podcast I'm [ __ ] dying
here dude I was playing video games I
was like yeah yeah I was just I mean I
was what is it called again in case we
forget Matt and Shane's secret podcast
yeah there you go oh yeah man that was
uh
it's not the way that was not the way no
it doesn't sound like the way
but I was looking so you got some good
stories out of it though and you lived
pretty good yeah pretty good but I lived
I was living according to a [ __ ] up
system and it was like things called
mental disorders got me out of it that's
what I'm trying to say